[Music]
Booth's audacious idea the inflationary
universe could push the limit of our
understanding back to the very first
moments of the very first second but how
could we ever test it how could we peer
into the birth of creation TV static
holds a clue 1% of the static on this
screen comes from light from the Big
Bang in 1964 astronomers Arno Penzias
and Robert Wilson were listening to
radio signals from space but in every
direction they were picking up a
background hum puzzled by the hum they
suspected they knew the culprit and
swept the entire receiver free of pigeon
droppings but to no avail if anything
the background got even greater and
according to legend when they gave a
talk at Princeton one physicist raised
his hand and says either you are
listening to the effects of bird
dropping or the creation of the universe
what Penzias and Wilson had stumbled
upon was the afterglow of the fireball
created by the Big Bang
as the universe expanded it cooled after
a few hundred thousand years it was just
protons and electrons flying around but
at some point the universe cooled enough
that when an electron and proton got
together all over the universe
essentially all at once
the universe became transparent think
about scientic fog that suddenly lifts
before the fog lifts you can only see a
few feet in front of you then suddenly
everything becomes clear that's what
happened 380,000 years after the Big
Bang ever since that moment 380,000
years after the Big Bang this light has
traveled uninterrupted through space and
scientists call it the Cosmic Microwave
Background if you were to write down a
handful of the greatest scientific
discoveries of all time one of them
might be the discovery of DNA another
one might be the discovery of the Cosmic
Microwave Background that's how big this
discovery was